One of the challenging things about
working with a language that uses
closures, is it's not always
particularly obvious when a piece of
code is going to be run.
When Gradle's invoked with
a name of a task to perform
it can't just go ahead and
execute that task.
It first has to figure out
that task dependency and
those task dependencies, and so on.
Gradle then executes all the tasks, and
in the correct order, before
the target task is eventually executed.
That means that before any
task execution happens,
the whole dependency
graph has to be created.
There are actually three phases to
the lifecycle of any Gradle build.
Initialization, configuration,
and execution.
The initialization phase is
mostly concerned with setting up
multi-project builds which we'll
talk about later in the course.
In the configuration phase
the build script is executing
which configures all
the project's tasks.
This is when a directed
acyclic task is built up and
Gradle determines which tasks need
to be run, and in which order.
Then finally, in the execution phase all
the task actions of all the tasks that
are chosen are executed
in the proper order.